warby parker which makes glasses filed
their s1 yesterday and they're planning
on going public by
direct listening somewhere bill gurley
is having a nice ice cold beer picking
his feet up and feeling great so before
we get into this warby parker let's do
uh just a quick primer on direct
listings there have been five notable
companies that recently went public via
a direct listing spotify slack palantir
roblox and coinbase spotify back in 2018
a true pioneer slack in 2019 palincher
in 2020 and then roblox and coinbase in
2021. so we're averaging about 1.5 of
these a year uh but it seems to be
ramping up obviously if orbeez parker
goes out this year that would be three
major direct listings let's break down
the differences between a direct listing
and a traditional ipo initial public
offering when you go public via direct
listing you don't have intermediaries
i.e investment banks underwriting your
shares so this is a little bit risky
because without the intermediary there
is no safety net guaranteeing the shares
will sell you don't go on the same what
they call the tour you don't go on the
same road show you don't have the
blessing of the big goldman sachs et
cetera for this reason companies that
have direct list have to have strong
brands and some level of notoriety
obviously with spotify and coinbase and
slack and roblox you have very high
profile companies they don't need to be
sold because they have a massive
footprint anybody who's in the stock
market knows those companies well now
with direct listings you also have no
lock-up periods that is
great for early employees and investors
like myself in traditional ipos there's
a lock-up period and that's between 90
and 180 days basically six months is
what you can expect that means when
robin hood goes public or uber went
public i can't sell my shares neither
can the uh folks who worked for a decade
uh or like me angel invested and held my
shares for a decade we can't sell who
can sell the banks the banks took it
public and their customers and clients
who they let have friends and family
shares and they can flip them
how is that fair that makes no sense
it's complete hypocrisy it's complete
inner kind of inside baseball dealing it
just screams of unfairness now uh direct
listings also have no further dilution
for shareholders in ipo they're you're
giving new shares of the company that
are created and that dilutes existing
shareholders of course you get money for
those in a direct listing you're
basically saying here are all the shares
that are available we got 100 million
shares or a billion shares of spotify
have at it start trading them
now
direct listings are also much less
expensive uh they take less time and
money than a traditional ipo and an ipo
these investment banks charge an
underwriting fee to do this whole
process for finding all these investors
for you and the underwriting fees are
charged on a percentage basis based on
how large the ipo is the more money the
company raises the lower percentage of
the fees pwc pricewaterhousecoopers
recently published an ipo price
calculator on their website based on the
average of 829 ipos and in deals greater
than a billion dollars the average
underwriter fee was 3.5
and the average investment banks on a
deal were 16.
so based on this you're spending 35
million dollars uh making your shares
available according to in jason
horowitz's breakdown apparently that's
some venture firm and social value i
haven't heard of them yet their direct
listings charge a flat advisory fee
which is typically half of what the
smallest underwriting fee for an ipo
would be
are you concerned about your portfolio's
performance in the near future jp morgan
blackrock and others are projecting
public equity returns of just three to
five percent over the next five years
analysts at bank of america urged
investors to consider real assets as
part of an inflation strategy so where
are the major players putting their
money endowments for yale harvard and
other top asset managers are looking
into alternative assets according to
masterworks research endowments over 1
billion are investing 55 more in
alternatives on average if you're
looking for a very interesting asset
class that's uncorrelated with the stock
market it's blue chip art masterworks
dot io sells shares in multi-million
dollar paintings by artists like banksy
picasso and warhol according to
masterworks contemporary art has
appreciated 14 annually from 1995 to
2020. out outperforming other real
assets like real estate and gold
i just had the founder scott lynn on the
program again episode 1232 for n
alternative assets roundtable and he
shared some great insights around
inflation appreciation more go listen to
episode 12 32
masterworks.io is a fantastic idea and
they're executing at a super high level
i think it's really genius so sign up
today at masterworks dot io and if you
use the code twist you'll skip their 30
000 person waitlist see important
information at masterworks dot io slash
disclaimer so let's dive into warby
parker's s1 the ltm revenue in other
words the trailing last 12 months of
revenue that's typically how we would
say in the business